OK, I'm here to tell you that a Fox News propagandist
was right about something, but I am not telling
you this to suggest that this is a good person
overall.
I'm merely telling you every once in a while
the right does something so depraved that
even the worst of the worst right wing clown
propagandists say this is too much for me
and it's a bad idea.
And I'm talking about Fox News host Sean HANNITY.
Sean HANNITY came out against the outrageous
armed protesters who have been showing up
with long guns and handguns, demanding states,
open businesses and stop the corona virus,
public health measures that actual doctors
and public health officials have determined
are necessary.
Let's take a look at the clip from Hannity's
program.
Down Policies Michigan.
I don't like this part in Michigan.
The number one supporter and radio and television
that I know of, First Amendment and the Second
Amendment.
Now, no one is a bigger defender of the Second
Amendment than yours truly.
Everyone has the right to protest, protect
themselves and try to get the country open.
This with the militia.
Look here.
And these long guns are no show of force is
dangerous.
That puts our police at risk.
And by the way, your message will never be
heard.
Whoever you people are, no one should be attempting
to intimidate officials with a show of force.
And God forbid something happens.
Then they're going to go after all of us law
abiding Second Amendment people.
I've been carrying a carry permit my whole
life.
All right.
So he's right.
I mean, these armed protesters are outrageous
and it's dangerous and it's a bad idea.
And HANNITY has sort of stumbled across the
right position the way a drunken guy at a
bar sometimes stumbles back to their car before
driving drunk and crashing the vehicle.
HANNITY also has personal reasons, like he
doesn't want the focus being on his guns,
which he thinks it might be if these nuts
keep showing up with rifles to state capitals
around the country.
And actor John Cusack actually made a similar
analogy.
He tweeted, quote, Now, not interesting, like
a blackout drunk, slurring an apology after
he crashed into innocent people.
He's a deranged pathological liar, enabler
for a death cult.
Nothing, he says, has any adult human value.
Now, I generally agree, but I think that there
is some value here.
One reason that this is more than just a broken
clock being right once or twice a day is we
know HANNITY has a huge real-world influence
on his audience.
A couple weeks ago, we found a we saw a study
that found that people who watch HANNITY as
a primary news source over Tucker Carlson
and other Fox News host, the HANNITY watchers
are more likely to have gotten coronavirus
realistically because HANNITY was more against
the lockdowns and downplayed the seriousness
of the virus.
Earlier on, his viewers saw that and were
encouraged to participate in riskier behavior,
which made them more likely to catch the virus.
So this actually does affect people.
And the point is that this is something when
you think about the role that Sean HANNITY
has for his audience, he's seen as like a
demigod by many of his viewers.
And if he says the armed protesters don't
make sense, this is too much, doesn't make
him a good person, doesn't make him right
about anything else that he said.
But it actually might mean someone, one of
his viewers decides not to show up with a
long gun.
And we're all better off for it.
We're all better off in every sense.
But let me step back for a second.
I'm going to be perfectly frank with you here.
I actually share Sean Hannity's frustration
with the protesters, but I also share the
frustration of the protesters.
I don't own guns.
I'm not showing up to protest.
And I don't think that the governors are the
people we should be protesting.
But I am outraged and frustrated and saddened
that what we've been doing hasn't worked because
there's been no proper federal coordination
of a functional national plan to deal with
the virus.
So I'm with the protesters in that I believe
what we've done has been worse for the economy
than it had to be.
But we don't want to blame the governors for
that.
We need to be blaming Donald Trump's administration.
The process should have been on day one of
a confirmed case.
That was January 20.
The Trump administration should have immediately
developed a working test like South Korea
did.
It wouldn't be reasonable to expect that Trump
would shut things down when we had like 15
cases.
But remember that March 5th, we already had
221 cases in the United States on March 5th.
Trump should have come out and said, let's
do a coordinated 50 state shutdown.
What we saw then happening in China.
Remember March 5, China?
Eighty thousand cases and we had 200 that
should have been enough.
When you look at Italy on March 5th, Italy
already had 4000 cases on March 5th.
So we knew how quickly it could spread in
other countries as well.
If on March 5, Trump had said, we're shutting
it down.
I need all 50 governors to do this with me.
We're gonna do this for you know, we wouldn't
have known at the time how long.
But today is May 5th, right?
We would be 60 days in to a federally coordinated
shutdown.
The spread would have been cut dramatically.
We wouldn't now have New York and Massachusetts
going down while Georgia, Florida and Texas
are exploding.
Right.
We could actually have coordinated this from
the top and really be looking at reopening
now.
Instead, we're in a situation where CDC and
FEMA believe we might be at three thousand
deaths a day by June 1st.
Italy's cases are way down.
Spain's cases are way down.
France's are way down.
South Korea, you know, they've managed to
keep this to a couple of hundred deaths total
and we still have one to two thousand deaths
a day.
And states are opening prematurely and cases
are spiking.
So my point is this.
If you want me to join the protesters in saying
this was mishandled, this didn't need to be
this bad for the economy.
I'm right there with you.
But protesting governors with guns is not
the right answer.
The right answer is hold the people accountable.
Who did the wrong thing?
The federal coordination failed us.
Those who should be held accountable are in
Washington, DC.
And of course, there are governors also acting
irresponsibly by wildly opening up or never
closing.
Let's hold them accountable now and let's
hold them accountable in November as well.